hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in the middle portion of prudentius's
poem psychomachia the battle for or
within the soul
there's two particular battles that are
very tough at least at first for the
virtues and it looks like the battle
might actually go against them and the
vices might win and there's two vices
that are really at the
center of this the first is
indulgence or luxury luxuria
and the second is greed averitzia
and both of these
wage war in a different way than the
earlier ones did like lust or
even pride
these are a bit more subtle challenges
and they throw the virtues into
confusion disarray
luxury even robs them as we're going to
find out of their courage but it turns
out that there is a virtue or set of
virtues that are particularly important
for
combating these
more difficult more demanding
opponents
so we we get indulgence first from the
far edges of the world where the sun
sets comes their enemy
indulgence and we have this really
interesting depiction reputation means
nothing to her she doesn't care about
that she's already lost that her curls
are perfumed her restless eyes are not
still her voice is languid
and bored so what we have here is a vice
pref personified the indulgence or
luxury the delighting in pleasures the
directing oneself that way is in fact
that kind of
being and what we find out is that she
lives for pleasure and she's not that
interested
in fighting as a matter of fact she'll
win her victory
over the virtues taking over the soul
in a much different way
as she arrives on the scene she is
lazily belching because of a long feast
she's just left she's self-indulgent she
comes at the dawn because she heard the
trumpets calling her to fight now how is
she going to fight
so her bare feet crush flowers on the
pavement she walks through puddles of
wine and perfume drunkenly she goes off
to war
in her chariot
her beauty inspires the army of her
compatriots the other
vices they're like wow this is this is
going to go good for us
and
prudencias goes on to say it's a strange
battle
she doesn't shoot arrows from her bow
no lances are hurled at the enemy's line
she holds no sword so what are her
weapons
well
flowers
flowers as items of beauty of indulgence
baskets of violets and roses two two
flowers that were particularly important
at that time blossoms she scatters the
virtues are won over by her charms
her sweetened breath
her strong odors
right
these things that that feel nice right
um that and her beauty
make the virtues lose
their courage their capacity to resist
and
their strength is
is uh
like she says crushed their courage
fails surely they've been defeated they
put down their weapons
and they gaze at the chariot they gaze
at the
tinkling harness the costly spokes as
this happens
the entire army finds itself pervaded
with an intense desire
to surrender so this is a big
catastrophe right the first four
of the combats have been won and now
the virtues are losing out to a single
big vice
but there's a virtue
that or one of the virtues can rally the
other ones sobriety
sobrietas
the opponent of self-indulgence
luxurious indulgence a virtue with a
strong will she weeps
and then she plants her flags and
restores their courage the virtues
courage with a speech she says
what blind madness troubles your
confused minds to whom have you pledged
allegiance you are fighters of iron how
can flowers restrain you and so she's
reminding them
of what they can do
and she she says to them where is the
tunic woven by faith
one of the very first of the virtues and
given as a protection to the young heart
she'd already renewed then she tells
them what will happen if they give in
you will be busy you'll attend great
banquets that last through the night
you'll spill wine and costly dishes your
couches will be soaked with drink and
the silk emblems will still be wet with
yesterday's dew and then she reminds
them of biblical stories remember the
thirst in the desert when the hebrews or
israelites are wandering with moses
remember the water that gushed from the
side of the rock when the prophet's
staff struck the stone and made a spring
where there was none were your father's
tents not filled with heavenly food was
this food not like that which christ
give us
after eating that well after such a
feast how can you let drunkenness and
wantedness take you to the den of
indulgence you're an army that survived
every threat neither the fury of wrath
nor idolatry could halt you but a
drunken dancer
is doing so and so she's rallying them
and telling them come do battle under
the flag and all the virtues will join
me in forcing that vice indulgence to
pay the great penalty she raises the
cross of christ high she pushes the holy
wood against the
horses of the chariot the beasts are
frightened and then sobriety
after the the chariot is is overturned
strikes the death blow by hurling a
great stone that she finds nearby it's
interesting because here we also have
the intervention of something that
doesn't seem to be either a vice or a
virtue
chance right
chance found the stone chance directs
its short flight so that the nose and
teeth of luxury are smashed her red lips
are driven into the arch of a ruined
mouth
sobriety then speaks up drink up you've
drained many cups before surely you can
stomach your own body you've reveled in
the excesses of sweetness you should
enjoy
morsels like these the taste of death
must be bitter in your mouth and then
luxury dies
then
all of those who are enjoying her
company
scatter the vices now flee and they
leave behind them all sorts of
spoils this is something that happened
in ancient battles right vanity is
stripped naked her long flowing robes
are dragged away the garlands that adorn
allurement are shredded the gold
ornaments are broken
and the confusion of strife shatters her
jewels pleasure is more happy to flee
through the throne the thorns with
injured feet and it goes on and on now
this looks like a
great win for the virtues and it is now
notice what they did they don't do
what they could have done and what they
don't do instead they don't take any of
this stuff they don't take trophies they
don't strip the battlefield
who does
well here's where the biggest challenge
so far shows up
greed avritiya comes on the scene and
greed we should point out
is one of the
main vices throughout
christian theology from the early period
all the way into later times so greed
folds up her robes and gathers up
everything left behind
when her pockets are filled
she stuffs money bags and purses with
her treasure
and then she's followed by as the poem
says a number of other
vices care hunger fear anxiety perjury
dread fraud fabrication sleeplessness
sordidness and we're going to find a
whole bunch of others pride of
possession you know these are all
nurtured by greed these are the
children of greed and what happens well
the human race
gripped by greed and these other vices
is involved in a great slaughter droves
of living things are destroyed and we
we read for example many men like pigs
are driven to furnaces where gold is
being burnt out of its rock each man
though it dooms him to death by fire
stretches his hand into the glowing
chamber hoping to find
gold of all the vices prudentius tells
us
there is none more frightening than
greed
greed wraps the lives of human beings in
calamities they only escape when they're
thrown to hell's fire something even
worse and so
fortunately
reason razio is there to protect as
prudentius will tell us the priests
the tribe of levi she her foster son she
covers them with her great shield and
saves them from the deadly rush of greed
with
reasons assistance the priests are saved
and remain strong and uninjured in the
battle only a few of them
feel the lance of greed and are only
scratched now greed realizes that
the battle is going against them and she
gives a
scream of rage and begins to speak she
says we are losing
we lack stamina we can't maintain our
attack our power to hurt is feeble
though before
none could resist us reason is what is
standing
in the way she says i and i alone
avaricious greed have brought to the
sticks all who have ever crossed that
current hell was enriched by us and it
is in our debt how can it be that now
our strength is turned aside well
fortune turns her twisted smile on our
weapons christians have no concern for
faces stamped on coins money right they
have no concern for hammered civil
silver no treasure has value for they
think it's glorious tarnish what does
this newly found fastidious pose mean we
won the iscariot judas who betrayed
christ um
with the most compelling reasons for
loyalty avarice destroyed him with only
a few coins why can't we do something
now and then
she does some trickery
she changes her bearing she changes her
appearance she lays her weapons aside
and changes what she looks like
in the form of undress of simple
austerity she becomes the virtue human
beings have known as thrift frugi
frugality right
and so now she is
hiding within the virtues themselves
ballona the goddess of war also takes on
the appearance of thrift as well
the battle line begins to falter the
virtues waver because their priestly
leaders are confined while the rank and
file is confounded the monster's
appearance easily misleads them they
cannot distinguish friend from foe
greed's appearance is a fluid and
changing thing so now once again
greed seems to be
winning
a vice seems to be taking out all the
other virtues
now we have another virtue that comes on
the scene to help us out
operazio which we can translate as good
works
good works is in a certain respect the
opposite
of greed at least in its actions right
it's not the opposite in disposition
perhaps
she enters the fight last putting her
hand in the battle she can guarantee
their success every impediment thrown
aside she moves through the ranks of
that armor or even a shield
once she had been heavy with riches and
money she she's now able to be freed by
helping the poor she scatters her
inheritance rich with faith she examines
her empty purse and estimates the value
of her estate in heaven with the
interest that accrues to it greed sees
good works and sees the writing on the
wall is dismayed tries to
get away
but
what happens
uh the virtue leaps on her
before the vice can escape her neck is
seized by hands as strong as iron greed
is being strangled
by good works squeezing blood from her
throat until it is dry and then she she
tells everybody take off your armor
honest men drop your weapons the cause
of our troubles is dead the pure can
rest now that the desire for gain
is gone it is good to wish for nothing
that is not needed
simple food one coat are enough to
refresh and case our weak bodies with
nature satisfied you need
there is no need for anything
more we're supposed to have faith
that we're going to be protected and
taken care of and now the rest of the
vices take off suffering fear violence
crime and fraud are
dispelled and the kind lady peace
comes onto the scene yet another of the
important virtues she expels the storms
of war
everybody is taking off their armor and
their weapons
and it looks like the battle has finally
been won
within the soul
greed
indulgence have been fought against the
appropriate virtues have come forward
and all the other vices
have left in
fear and dismay
you